dann hat ganz europa letzten sonntag
kollektiv kuh gemacht beziehungsweise
auf französisch
emanuel makro bleibt französischer
präsident herzlichen glückwunsch
wirklich
glückwunsch zu 58 prozent
leider dass die schlechte nachricht hat
marine le pen in der stichwahl mit 41
prozent ihr persönliches rekordergebnis
erzielt man könnte sagen für die eu war
das so etwas wie der letzte warnschuss
in beide kniescheiben
entsprechend groß die erleichterung am
wahlabend für den die kollegen von welt
ev zum glück einen dolmetscher gebucht
hatten denn sonst hätte ich kein wort
verstanden
danke
das so
dann heißt die furchtbare schokolade
also danke das musste
so für viele franzosen weiß natürlich
die berühmte wahl zwischen pest und
cholera ein als elitär geltender banker
gegen eine gelernte rechtspopulisten
aber im manual hat das problem längst
erkannt und postet jetzt nur noch fotos
auf denen er aussieht wie einer von uns
nur halt viel schöner und mit einem
überfahrenen frettchen auf der brust
man kann werde ich nur sagen armes
frankreich konservative partei
pulverisiert sozialisten 6 am ende stand
marco ganz alleine gegen den ziemlich
extremen rest ja
2027 dafür nicht mehr antreten schlägt
dann die stunde von marine le pen wie
gesagt 41 prozent der franzosen haben
die gewählt in dieser welt lage was
besonders alarmierend ist 67 prozent der
französischen arbeiter zwei von fünf
franzosen will le pen zwei von fünf ist
wirklich erschreckend oder ja vor allem
weil die frau selbst nach der krim
annexion wenig hehl gemacht hat aus
ihrem putin crash sie sagten sie hätten
eine gewisse bewunderung für putin ja
ich bewundere seinen kühlen kopf ich
bewundere es auch dass er es geschafft
hat einer großen nation die 70 jahre
lang gedemütigt und unterdrückt wurde
stolz und lebensfreude zurückzugeben ja
der flagge der sprüht quasi vor
lebensfreude er ist der ideale nachbarn
also außer dass er gern mal unangemeldet
zu besuch kommt aber sonst mit sowas
wohl trotzdem 41 prozent woran wir
erkennen viele wähler
interessieren sich gar nicht für
geopolitik sondern eher für
alltagsprobleme und wenn rechtsextreme 1
können dann so tun als ob sie sich um
die sorgen von kleinen leuten scheren
sie haben sich um die straßenbeleuchtung
um die parkplätze gekümmert und alle
haben gesagt das sind ja gar keine nazis
die gute nachricht erst wenn sie
anfangen autobahn zu bauen wenn es eng
wird es ist das ist ein erfahrungswert
tatsächlich sind weltweit die populisten
wieder auf dem vormarsch und das liegt
nicht zuletzt an der series verdammten
inflation ja an der rasanten
preissteigerung also die rechten haben
dafür natürlich keine lösung klar aber
sie sind viel besser im melden des
problems aktuelle umfrage aus dieser
woche 23 prozent der deutschen sparen
schon bei lebensmitteln und produkten
des täglichen bedarfs sie müssen ja
hoffentlich hat die ampel verstanden
welche sprengkraft das thema inflation
hat zumal die populisten ja auch im
internet deutlich mehr aufmerksamkeit
kriegen wird das jetzt noch schlimmer wo
ausgerechnet elon musk also der reichste
troll der welt twitter kauft fragt sich
friedemann weise
wo waren sie als bekannt wurde dass elon
musk twitter kaufen will ich war
natürlich auf twitter dem ort wo die
hetzen und wuchsen ob in leder ihre
härtesten text robben ich habe
angekündigt dass ich nach der
parlamentarischen sommerpause
mit dem zittern beginnen werde
das blatt das findet jetzt statt
das war übrigens auch sein einziger
tweet danach hat er das faxgerät wieder
rausgeholt auf jeden fall sorgte die
nachricht für ordentlich wirbel im netz
lauterbach sah gleich die demokratie
gefährdet er warnte vor der
kommerzialisierung des internets ja
wissen viele gar nicht bisher wurde
twitter genau wie facebook und instagram
ehrenamtlich von ein paar nonnen der
heilsarmee betrieben manche glauben
sogar dass die twitter übernahme nie
zustande kommt und nur ein taktisches
manöver ist um die tesla aktie zu
manipulieren aber warum sollte ein
seriöser geschäftsmann so was tun
[Gelächter]
okay ich habe nichts gesagt genauso
gefreut haben sich natürlich die tromm
fans die hoffen dass der könig der hate
speech wieder twittern darf dann heißt
es endlich wieder den ganzen tag
ja es kann sein dass trumps twitter
sperre aufgehoben wird wenn ihr an mast
sieht sich selbst als free speech
absolut ist er will die totale
meinungsfreiheit erst gegen zensur und
will dass jeder immer alles sagen darf
außer über ihn natürlich was kritik
angeht scheint der amerikanische
unternehmer ohnehin dünnhäutig das zdf
war heute ausgesperrt worden mass karte
sich an kritischen beiträgen des senders
während der bauphase gestoßen ganz schön
unentspannt für den käfer aber er ist
nicht immer so dünnhäutig als wir den
kanadischen premier cru dom mit hitler
verglich hat meist sogar gelöscht und
sich bei hitler entschuldigt sorry
andersrum hitler hat sich bei ihm egal
ich freue mich auf jeden fall darauf
wenn er da vinci der neuzeit seinen
erfindergeist zu twitter bringt neben
tesla und spacex hat er noch eine firma
die das menschliche gehirn direkt mit
dem computer verbinden will da kann man
bald beim kacken twittern und hat
trotzdem beide hände frei zum beispiel
zum gitarrespielen
ein kritischer arzt ein schwuler soldat
eine kämpferin für ein groß kalifat eine
freude ist future
schulschwänzerin eine
querschnittsgelähmte
bauchtänzerin eine hebamme und ein it
spezialist kann aber auch sein dass das
er gleich ist ein nazi aus sachsen in
nazi aus kiel ein almut boller die in
zivil ein ex banker und ein ex offizier
eine expertin und eine ex von mir ein
kleiner flüchtling aus kandahar ein nazi
aus sachsen aber ein anderer auf twitter
kommen alle zusammen und dann
schreien sie sich an
[Musik]
dankbar
so
aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and cut
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reich